so many people are excited about
hogwarts legacy but there are some
questions that i see asked online over
and over and over and over and over over
again so that's why in today's video
we're going to be taking the top 11
hogwarts legacy questions asked on
youtube and answering them for you as
quickly as we possibly can here in
today's video number one is hogwarts
legacy on xbox as long as you don't mean
the original xbox or the xbox 360
then yes hogwarts legacy is listed on
the official website as coming to both
the xbox one as well as the xbox series
s and x number two is hogwarts legacy
multiplayer as far as the official word
goes no right now avalanche has not
announced any sort of multiplayer with
the game whatsoever and as of right now
anything you hear about multiplayer
being in the game is pure speculation
number three is hogwarts legacy on ps4
why yes yes it is at the time of this
recording hogwarts legacy is still
listed as coming to the ps4 on the
avalanche website number four is
hogwarts legacy cancelled really you're
really you're really gonna ask me that
the answer is no it's not cancelled it's
hogwarts legacy on pc absolutely
hogwarts legacy is slated to come to pc
when it launches in who knows when
number six is hogwarts legacy open world
indeed it is open world and this has
actually been confirmed directly by
avalanche okay this next one might be
the one that i see so many times in the
comments of people still being confused
by this number seven is hogwarts legacy
an mmo no it is not an mmo as we said in
the answer before it is open world but
it's being developed as an open world
action rpg and not an mmo remember mmo
is massively multiplayer online
role-playing game number eight is
hogwarts legacy a ps5 exclusive
absolutely not even though it was
originally unveiled at sony's ps5
showcase event it is still coming to
multiple platforms including pretty much
everything except for the nintendo
switch number nine is hogwarts legacy
out yet unfortunately no it's not out
yet number 10 is hogwarts legacy cross
platform i'm not actually sure what is
intended by this question because it is
going to be on multiple platforms
however usually when you think of
something being cross-platform you think
of something that can be played across
different platforms such as fortnite for
example where it doesn't matter if
you're on a ps4 or a pc or xbox you can
all play together but since there hasn't
been any multiplayer component confirmed
for hogwarts legacy then i'm a little
confused on what is meant by this
question so it's on multiple platforms
yes but cross-platform in terms of how
it plays
no and then number 11 is hogwarts legacy
still coming out absolutely yes it is
although the game was originally slated
to release in 2021 and although we are
still waiting on news here in 2022
avalanche has promised that news is
coming and this year hopefully that
still means the game is coming this year
as well for that we'll have to wait and
find out if you're even more curious
about how the gameplay of hogwarts
legacy will play out in terms of how it
may actually be inspired by the legend
of zelda breath of the wild then be sure
and check out the video on the right
side of your screen now where i break
down some insane information that we
just recently learned about the game as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon